Laughter is one of those rare and beautiful things shared by people all over Earth,...
...a human experience that transcends borders of language, geography, and lifestyle.
No one has to teach us to laugh, and people everywhere do it pretty much the same way.
But it's also really, really strange.
Humans laugh for a number of reasons,...
...but most of the time it has nothing to do with funny business.
Researchers like Robert Provine have found,...
...after listening to hundreds of people laugh in social situations,...
...less than one in five chuckles are in response to humor,...
...and when a joke is involved,...
...the person telling it is far more likely to be the one laughing.
We're also 30 times more likely to laugh with other people around than if we're alone.
If laughter is a form of communication, then what are we trying to say?
We do it to communicate understanding, to show we like and accept others,...
...to diffuse awkward situations,...
...and yes, sometimes even to be mean.